nous avons reçu une question de denis
garant il nous explique qu'il doit
souvent s'absenter du travail pour aider
sa mère malade
il aimerait savoir ce que les parties
prévoient dans cette campagne électorale
pour soutenir les proches aidants du
côté du parti libéral du québec il n'y a
pour l'instant pas eu d'annoncé pas de
plan dans cette campagne électorale mais
ça devrait arriver incessamment sous peu
nous dit-on dans l'entourage de philippe
couillard
il faut savoir justement que son
gouvernement avait déjà adopté dans le
dernier budget une bonification soutien
aux aidants naturels 100 millions de
dollars supplémentaires d'ici 2023 au
parti québécois le chef jean françois
lisée propose d'augmenter le financement
du soutien à domicile d'au moins 100
millions de dollars par année pendant
cinq ans donc à terme 2 500 millions de
dollars par année une somme versée
directement aux six est aux cieux ce qui
en théorie devrait vous fournir des
soins de santé à domicile gratuitement
si vous en avez besoin
par contre pour l'instant il n'est pas
question d'augmenter ou de diminuer le
crédit d'impôt pour aidants naturels
donc bénéficier chez la coalition avenir
québec on promet que si on forme le
prochain gouvernement
on va déposer rien de moins que la
politique nationale pour les prochains
dans et dans le cadre de cette politique
on va venir bonifier et vous d'un coup
qui offert aux personnes qui aident
leurs proches
et ces gens là vont pouvoir aller
chercher jusqu'à 2500 $ par année à la
fin du premier mandat de gouvernement
kaki ce petit 9 chez québec solidaire on
veut également offert une aide
financière au prochain dans si vous avez
d'autres questions d'autres commentaires
écrivez nous avons élections @ radio
radio canada.ca